>> WELCOME BACK, EVERYONE.
IN JAPAN THE NOW FORMER
PRINCESS MAKO HAS WEB HER
COLLEGE SWEETHEART AFTER YEARS
OF CONTROVERSY.
BY MARRYING A COMMONER SHE
CHOSE TO RELINQUISH THE ROYAL
LIFE AND HER TITLE.
SHE IS ALSO FOREGOING A 1
MILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT.
THE CEREMONY WAS A MUTED AND
PRIVATE AFFAIR, BUT AFTERWARDS
MAKO AND HER NEW HUSBAND HELD A
PRESS EVENT AND SPOKE OF THEIR
LOVE FOR ONE ANOTHER.
THEY ALSO ADDRESSED THE INTENSE
SCRUTINY OVER THEIR
RELATIONSHIP.
OUR BLAKE ESSIG JOINS US NOW
LIVE FROM TOKYO TO TALK ABOUT.
THIS THE COUPLE HAS COME UNDER
EXTREME PRESSURE AND AS A
RESULT THIS WAS NOT A JOYFUL
WEDDING BUT INSTEAD FULL OF
APOLOGIES.
TALK TO US ABOUT THAT AND WOULD
ALL HAS BEEN SAID ABOUT THEM.
>> NOT THE ROYAL WEDDING THAT
YOU WOULD EXPECT JAPAN'S FORMER
PRINCESS MAKO AND HER HUSBAND A
COMMONER KEI KAMURO, IF YOU'RE
EXPECTING A ROYAL FAIRYTALE
WEDDING, PAIR TO BE
DISAPPOINTED.
NO POMP AND CIRCUMSTANCE
WHATEVER.
A REASON FOR THE SCALE BACK
AFFAIR HAD A LOT TO DO WITH THE
INTENSE PUBLIC SCRUTINY THAT
HAS TAKEN ITS TOLL ON THE
COUPLE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
IN FACT, THE NOW FORMER
PRINCESS RECENTLY DISCLOSED
THAT SHE SUFFERS FROM COMPLEX
POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AS A RESULT OF HER RELATIONSHIP
BEING PICKED APART OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
SINCE THE ENGAGEMENT WAS
ANNOUNCED IN 2017 THE
RELATIONSHIP HAS BEEN MET WITH
SCANDAL, PUBLIC DISAPPROVAL,
AND MEDIA SCANDAL ACCORDING TO
REPORTS THAT HER MOTHER FAILED
TO PAY BACK MONEY THAT SHE WORE
IT FROM A FORMER FIANCÉE.
DESPITE THE STRAP EXTRAVAGANT
OF THEIR MOST PEOPLE HOPE TO
SEE, THE COUPLE SIMPLY REGISTER
THEIR MARRIAGE EARLIER THIS
MORNING, AROUND 10 O'CLOCK
LOCAL TIME, BEFORE HOLDING A
BRIEF PRESS EVENT IN THE
AFTERNOON.
THEY PUBLICLY EXPRESS THEIR
LOVE FOR EACH OTHER, THINK THE
PUBLIC FOR THEIR SUPPORT, AND
DISCUSSED WHAT THEY FELT WERE
UNFOUNDED RUMORS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> [INTERPRETER]
KAYE WAS CRITICIZED A RICHER
EARLY, AND THE SPECULATION THAT
HE DID NOT CARE FOR ME SPREAD.
TRULY UNILATERAL.
OUR LOVE IS TRUE AND.
REAL THESE FALSE RUMORS SPREAD
QUICKLY, WHICH MADE ME FEARFUL.
I FACE GREAT PAIN AND SADNESS
FROM THIS.
>> AND NOW THE REASON THAT THE
EVENT WAS HELD IN THIS WAY,
WHICH THEY ONLY ANSWERED, WHILE
THEY DIDN'T ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS JUST GAVE A BRIEF
STATEMENT, WAS TO PROTECT THE
FORMER PRINCESSES FROM ANY
FURTHE